vous parlez de nouveau concept pour la
campagne municipale c'est un panel qui
va revenir plusieurs fois par semaine
qui va s'accélérer avec moi donc
que vous connaissez ex mairesse de
Villeray Saint-Michel Parc Extension
Express vice-président du comité
exécutif
avec lui vous êtes cons fondatrice sont
partis
merci à vous deux
vous vous connaissez et vous amener le
monde municipale et c'est pour ça qu'on
est allé vous chercher question plutôt
général au début mais les yeux sur le
match revanche en Grèce et Monsieur
Couderc qu'est-ce qui vous frappe
jusqu'ici sur la station général mais
elle était un peu sur les chapeaux de
roues pour les deux il y a eu la cuisine
donc c'est sûr que la relation avec
l'histoire est quoi la main que je fais
les deux les deux chacun un mandat déjà
alors qu'ils peuvent nous présenter donc
les deux ont des résultats sont capables
de regarder leur tableau plaisir que
j'ai mis ce que j'ai pas aimé et c'est
de nouveau parti avec des nouvelles
personnes des jeunes qui veulent faire
leur place donc les gens qui ne veulent
pas voter pour un ou pour l'autre on
rentre peut-être aussi le choix de
regarder les autres première vidéo
persil qui sont à la lumière j'ai j'ai
pu lire un peu leur documents c'est
quand même
mais effectivement les deux portes Denis
et Valérie porte débile hein on a des
femmes qui est bon loto s'il y a des
idées qui était bonne il y a des choses
qui ont été moins bonne pour les deux
mais les deux parts à égalité d'en
trouver un qui se sont les meilleures
personnes pour la prochaine campagne il
faut que j'ai vraiment rien bien sûr
hein. C'est intéressant vous êtes
l'équipe est intéressante parce que il y
a comme un changement de génération mais
il y a des gens qui peuvent ou fin de la
campagne qui
gagne exactement et surtout avec le
temps je pense que c'est
les premiers mois c'est les serments
démo de recrutement parce que c'est
important pour des câlins date d'arrivée
rapidement pour pouvoir faire campagne
chercher du financement chercher des
appuis commencer le porte-à-porte avec
moi j'ai regardé le recrutement et puis
je dois dire que Monsieur Kader
parce que d'abord sur une Wii avec son
ancien partis ensemble
et
on
va
[Musique]
engagé ça t'intéresse
il y a plein de
celui qui
a
tous les jours et j'espère que
on est là pour les aider à part leur
choix
qu'est-ce que vous pensez
écouter rapidement
sécuritaire les gens on part
rien à faire puisque c'est la fin de
Toulon
il y en a
parlé aux policiers parler à la
population de Montréal n'est pas
sécuritaire je pense que c'est porter
ombrage et c'est d'envoyer un message
comme quoi le des des des des policiers
des policière du milieu communautaire
n'était pas efficace qui ça c'est trop
bien leur travail c'est pour ça les
messages qu'on doit leur faire
la déclaration de Montréal mais plus
sécuritaire
le point négatif de Madame plan si tu as
quelques mois dans l'année passée au
début de l'été on avait commencé à
parler de revoir le financement de la
police de désarmer les policiers de rien
version dans le communautaire le seul
point positif c'est mettre de l'argent
dans le communautaire mais pour habiller
Paul pour
pour moi la police doit faire son
travail actuellement c'est beaucoup plus
la prévention qui va se régler problème
actuellement en traitement un choc on va
trouver les places on enlève les fusils
mais il faut pas qu'il revienne propos
viennent pour revenir sur ce travail de
terrain avec nous organisme
communautaire on en parlait souvent mais
je veux pas vous laisser aller sans
parler de la mobilité c'est le gros
thème de la dernière campagne municipale
est-ce que on a fait du chemin
voilà la première année d'avoir demi
et lui arriver un
problème de congestion de d'accès au
centre-ville arrive la deuxième
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont plus de
voiture
[Musique]
de nous voir le meilleur aussi les
piétons et aussi les personnes
handicapées et aussi les voitures et tu
sais comment on est capable de tout le
monde ensemble actuellement ils vont au
détriment de la communauté plutôt que 1
ans